in an online world where every click
could be a Potential Threat and every
second counts toward safeguarding your
digital life stands a silent Vigilant
protector welcome to the realm of
endpoint detection and response or Ria
The Cutting and shield in the unending
battle against cyber threats did you
know that every 39 seconds a Cyber
attack occurs somewhere on the globe
impacting Millions annually but fear not
for EDR is the advanced Sentinel ever
evolving to Outer the most sophisticated
of digital adversaries as we navigate
through the complex web of cyber
security EDR emerges as the beon of Hope
continuously monitoring detecting and
responding to threats that seek to
infiltrate our digital centuries today
we are not just discussing a technology
we are unveiling a formidable force in
cyber security we will delve into the
heart of EDR exploring its mechanisms
its might and its critical role in
securing our digital Frontiers and
before commencing just a quick quick
info for you if you are an aspiring
cyber security professional looking for
online training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learns postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice through our courses you
will gain knowledge and B ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others this course is
designed to accommodate a diverse range
of Learners and this course requires
just a bachelor's degree with a 50% of
average and no prior programming
experience required and one plus year of
work experience is preferred if you're
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin comment and
description box below so let's get
started without any further Ado so first
we'll understand what EDR is so let's
start at the beginning endpoint
detection and response is a cyber
security approach focused on
continuously monitoring and user devices
detecting suspicious activities and
responding swiftly to eliminate threats
from its Inception as a simple antivirus
to its current sophisticated form EDR
has transformed into a proactive defense
mechanism so this was about EDR now
we'll see how EDR works so let's delve
into the mechanisms of how it functions
endpoint detection and response operates
on a simple yet powerful principle
continuous monitoring and real-time
response but what does this look like in
practice let's break it down it starts
with detection EDS systems continuously
monitor end points for any signs of
malicious activity this isn't just about
scanning for know viruses it's about
understanding normal behaviors and
sporting anomalies whether it's an
unusual login attempt or an unexpected
file encryption EDR is always watching
Always analyzing when something
suspicious is detected the response
mechanism kicks in this can make make
many forms from simple alerts to
automatic isolation of the affected
device in some cases EDS systems can
even remove or contain the threat
automatically stopping it in tracks
before it can do more harm but EDR isn't
just about reacting it's about learning
and adapting through continuous
monitoring the system gathers data over
time learning from each interaction and
becoming more adapt at identifying
threats this means that the more it's
used the smarter and more effective it
becomes and let's not forget the human
element while EDR systems do a lot of
the heavy lifting they're often
supported by security teams who analyze
alerts investigate incidents and refine
the systems parameters this partnership
between human and machine is what makes
EDR so powerful EDR works by
continuously monitoring end points
detecting threats through sophisticated
analysis responding in real time to
contain and neutralize those threats and
constantly learning from each
interaction to improve its defenses it's
an ever Vigilant ever adapting system
designed to keep your digital
environment secure and with EDR you're
not just defending against the threats
of today you're preparing for the
challenges of tomorrow it's a dynamic
proactive approach to cyber security
that ensures your network is always one
step ahead so this was how EDR works now
we'll see the key features of EDR
Solutions so starting with the key
features the number one feature is
behavioral analysis so it monitors
normal user and system Behavior to
establish a baseline it allows the
system to detect deviations indicating
potential threats including new and
sophisticated Mala types that
traditional signature based methods
might miss and the next feature is
threat hunting so proactive search for
hidden threats within the system so it
goes beyond waiting for alerts actively
seeking out and identifying potential
threats before they manifest into actual
breaches ensuring a more secure
environment now coming to the next
feature that is incident response so it
automates or guides processes for
addressing detected threats quick and
efficient response reduces the impact of
attacks by isolating affected end points
and initiating remediation minimizing
downtime and damage so this was the next
feature now moving to the next feature
that is realtime monitoring and
Reporting so continuous surveillance and
Analysis of the network and endpoint
activities so it provides immediate
alerts or suspicious activities and comp
comprehensive reports for in-depth
analysis that is crucial for timely
threat detection and long-term security
strategy planning now mve to the next
key feature that is integration with
existing systems so capability to
function cohesively with current
security and it infrastructure so it
ensures that the Eds solution enhances
and complements existing security
measures providing a more robust defense
without disrupting existing workflows
and the next feature is scalability so
the ability to grow and adapt to the
expanding needs of an organization is
scalability feature as your business
grows so do your security needs
scalability ensures that your EDS
solution can handle an increasing load
and more complex environments without
compromising protection so this was
about this feature now moving to the
next that is user interface and
usability so the design and
functionality of the Ed systems user
interface is about this feature a
userfriendly interface ensures that
security teams can effectively navigate
and utilize the system making it easier
to manage and respond to threats thereby
enhancing overall security efficiently
so this was about the key features now
we see how to choose the right EDR
solution so choosing the right EDR
solution so the first point to consider
is understanding your needs so assess
the size of your network the type of
data you handle and your existing
security infrastructure identify what's
most critical to protect so moving to
the next point that would be integration
capabilities so ensure the edier
solution integrate seamlessly with your
current security setup to create a
cohesive defense without adding
unnecessary complexity now moving to the
next point for consideration that is
scalability choosing an ed solution that
can grow with your organization adapting
to an evolving threat landscape and
expanding Network and the next is user
interface and management op for a system
with an intuitive user interface and
clear reporting your team should manage
and understand the system effectively
then we have performance and accuracy
consider the Solutions detection rates
and false positives it should accurately
identify threats without overwhelming
you with false alarms and the next is
cost consideration evaluate the total
cost of ownership including initial
purchase implementation ongoing
maintenance and unnecessary and
necessary upgrades aim for the best
value and now moving to the next point
that is vendor reputation and support so
choose a vendor with a strong track
recording cyber security robust support
and a commitment to continuously update
their solu Solutions so this was about
the points for choosing the right Ed
solution now moving to the challenges
and considerations so the first
challenge you can face is managing false
positives so false positive occur when
the Eds system mistakenly identifies
Banning activities as threats leading to
unnecessary alerts this can cause alert
fatigue among your security team and
divert attention from real threats so
there's a solution for it you can
regularly review and adjust the system
sensitivity and alert thresholds
employee continuous training and
tweaking to ensure accuracy and
efficiency and the next challeng is
resource requirements so effective EDR
management requires a team with
specialized knowledge in cyber security
and the specific edia tool in use
finding and retaining such talent can be
challenging and the solution for this
can be you can invest in training for
your current team consider hiring
external experts or partner with managed
security service providers to supplement
your internal capabilities now moving to
the next challenge that is privacy
concerns so EDS systems Monitor and
collect a load of data from end user
devices raising concerns about user
privacy and data protection laws so so
we can ensure transparency about data
collection practices obtain necessary
consents Implement strict access
controls and comply with all prevalent
privacy regulations now moving to the
next challenge that is integration and
compatibility so EDS is systems need to
integrate seamlessly with existing
security infrastructure incompatibility
can create gaps in defense and increase
complex ability so there's a solution
for this you can choose an EDI solution
that offers flexible and Broad
integration capabilities with your
existing security tools and
infrastructure ensured it scalable and
adaptable to Future changes so in
conclusion Ando detection and response
ad stands as an indispensable component
of modern cyber security strategies
offering not just a defense mechanism
but a proactive approach to identifying
and neutralizing threats it's clear that
while EDR presents certain challenges
such as managing false positives
resource allocation privacy concerns and
integration complexities these can be
effectively navigated with the right
strategies and solutions amasing EDR is
not merely about adapting new technology
but also fostering a culture of
continuous vigilance and adaption in the
face of evolving cyber threats as we
move forward in this digital age and
understanding and implementing EDR is
not just an option it's a fundamental
step towards ensuring robust resilient
cyber security defenses and there you
have it folks if you like this session
then like share and subscribe if you
have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the Link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here